and let me just say this and i'm gonna
have more to say about this more to
write about this at pft it kind of got
lost in the shuffle last night because
we were focused on the pics you saw that
image there of joe burrow with his
parents and no one else around there
were a lot of images last night that
troubled me as it relates to the
stay-at-home guidelines the social
distancing guidelines there were a lot
of agents who traveled from their homes
to the homes of their clients in other
states a lot of them did it a lot of
them
and you're violating stay-at-home orders
you're ignoring social distancing
guidelines and i'm stunned that so many
did it i'm stunned that so many made
their way into the tv shots and i'm
stunned that the nflpa hasn't said
anything about it and i hope the union
does because the union regulates the
agents and at a time when i think the
union is doing a very good job of
sending the right messages and setting
the right tone when it comes to the
pandemic and how to handle the
coronavirus and all of that the idea
that i don't know half of the agents
last night representing the top 32 picks
got on a plane and flew from presumably
a state with a stay-at-home order to
another state with a stay-at-home order
to be in the house to be in the shot to
be on tv with their client that to me
that's that's the most overlooked
development last night that is yet to
fully be explained discussed and
analyzed in part because we've got 32
picks to analyze but i just wanted to
hit pause right there chris and point
that out because burrow did it the right
way his agents weren't there it was him
and his parents so many of these other
shots it sent a message that doesn't
mesh with everything we've been told for
the last five weeks
yeah well no i mean mike i thought about
you a number of times you're right we
saw a lot of draft picks breaking the
social distancing rules we definitely
did uh and you know free agents as well
it's a tough decision you know again you
know some of these draft picks this is a
life-defining moment they got family
over that's close to them i mean we
didn't see big parties or gatherings or
anything like that but certainly
pushing the limits
there was a lot of people in the house a
lot more than the six that the nfl told
them could be present in the shot
well this is why i'm hopeful that you
know the the you know i just don't think
players care i don't you know again i
told you what i thought if i was a 26
year old nfl football player i'd be like
screw cove at 19 let's play football and
i'm not saying that's right i'm just
telling you that's the mentality of a
young kid who loves football and it's
part of the renegade football mentality
that's just the way most of us are wired
but regardless i'm with you it just sets
a bad example it's going to embolden
people to maybe have a small draft party
tonight while they're watching friday
night because they're going to go look
there was 15 people in that house there
was 12 people in that house why can't i
have a few buddies over and watch the
draft tonight
and and let me just say one last thing
before we move on i understand that
there are players who are going to feel
like they're invincible they're immune
they're fine
there are plenty of nfl players and
college players for that matter who are
morbidly obese it goes with the
territory of being an offensive or
defensive lineman and let me tell you
something all it takes is one of those
guys to die from this and it's all
getting shut down
until there's a vaccine until testing is
as easy as pressing a button and that's
that's one of the real concerns here so
enough
of that for now but i wanted to at least
plant a flag and say i was very troubled
by what i saw last night because
ultimately that's a product that the nfl
is pulling out of these homes and piping
into millions of other homes and i wish
that someone would have said we're not
going we're not showing that image no no
no no no sorry we know we got the camera
in the house we're not showing that
image because we don't want to send that
message to the rest of the world chris
and i think the nfl should have been
willing to do that well no i hear you i
mean you're right and then hopefully
they'll send out some notice to some of
these people tonight but you know let's
let's save this topic for monday when
the draft is over okay but let's get
into the draft and the picks of the
players right now but this is exactly
why no one's going to talk about it
today this is why it's important for us
to talk about it we can't just press
pause on reality and say oh it's oh they
get an exception no they don't get an
exception we need to hold them
accountable by monday we move on today
it's worth saying now we can move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports